hello everyone we are back at the
Capablanca saga I hope you are all
having a wonderful Sunday because we are
at the final round of the first part of
the 1914 tournament in st. Petersburg
it's horrible Capablanca versus Joseph
Henry Blackburn now we've covered a few
games by Joseph Henry Blackburn before
some of his better games you all know
they called him the Black Death or or
indulge their shots at thought after his
great performance in the 1873 Vienna
tournament that is that's unconfirmed
but you know it is the general opinion
but if you have some further knowledge
to this you know do share in the
comments and now the first thing you
will see in the description below will
be two links to two games by Joseph
Henry Blackburn if you're new subscriber
to this channel or if you've just
stumbled upon this video so do check it
out so you get get an idea of what kind
of a player Joseph Henry Blackburn was
because this is not the Joseph Henry
Blackburn in his prime just Henry
Blackburn here in the 1914 tournament of
son Peter Berg is already 73 years old
so it's some forty forty years have
passed since Blackburn was in his prime
when he you know the defeated players
like Steinitz and such but ok still
definitely a strong player and still a
lot of knowledge in this guy but yeah
he's like he's so old that when
Blackburn was a Blackburn was already a
teenager when Murphy was conquering
Europe and it was a it was actually
morphicon quest of Europe that led to
Joseph and Blackburn to you know take a
take on chess before that it was mostly
a mostly drops man but ok that being
said let's check out this very nice game
capablanca has the white pieces and of
course Capablanca opens with E 4 we have
E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now
Bishop to b5 purple uncle goes for the
reuleaux PES and here already an
interesting move by Blackburn Knight
study for the birds defense and it's a
it's a nice line you I mean you can play
it of course if you're playing against a
really weak opponents maybe they will
even capture the five pawn and then you
can just win the game immediately with
Queen to g5 now you're attacking the
knight if the knight moves you can
pick up the bishop on b5 or you can go
for the g2 pawn for example Knight f3
let's say you capture here doesn't
really matter
the knight is attacked twice the rook is
under attack and wide it just falls
apart it's a similar idea in the Italian
game when you don't go Bishop to b5 when
you go be sure to c4 again you can go a
night before and then if captures you
can finish the game with with great
style if your opponent goes for Knight
captures on f7 attacks the rook captures
rook at 1 and how you can go Queen
captures with Czech Bishop blocks and 9
of 3 a nice smothered mate so ok it's a
similar idea like in the Italian but
here it's a bit different but still the
thread behind capturing d5 point is
Queen g5 I would an attack against the
g2 upon and the night
so just to cover that but ok couple
Monica goes Knight captures on d4 in
detail and you can also kick the night
with c3 but here your Bishop is under
attack Knight captures pawn captures and
now comes castles the Capablanca so
what's a really blacks compensation for
this doubled pawn well blacks plan is to
play c6 and take advantage of now the
bishop isn't looking all that great and
b5 black will play C's c6 97 and then
push to d5 to break the center so I mean
it's playable g6 by Blackburn we have D
3 by capablanca and now Bishop to g7
Knight the d2 we have 97 as planned c6 d
5 is coming and here comes F for you do
you know you want to play Knight f3 but
before that you want to put upon to a4
so the knight doesn't block the F pawn
we have c6 now taking advantage of the
bishops funny position
Bishop to c4 and now d5 breaking the
center and of course cerca Blanca does
not wish to capture here we have Bishop
to b3 and now black castles we have
Knight to f3 by Capablanca improving the
position of the night also now the
bishop may come into play at some point
and we have c5 now Blackburn's plan is
to push b5 and c4 and try to trap the
bishop of course he's not hoping to win
the bishop he just wants to expand on
the
inside and also take advantage of this
bishop looking awkward on the queenside
one of the reasons sorry about that no
idea how I did that haha why this night
the default plan is playable for black
and here we have e 5 aqua Blanca takes
more space in the center and now comes
b5 now c4 definitely is a threat so
kappa blanka needs to figure out what to
do with the bishop
we have c3 making some room and c2 for
the Bishop c4
we have Bishop to see - and now D
captures on c3 we have B captures on c3
and now Queen to a5 going after the c3
pawn and capablanca defense Bishop to d2
we have Bishop to g4 now painting the
night and here
d4 capablanca blocks the center and he
will figure out where to go for from
them he wants to play h3 the side black
will have to decide what to do with the
bishop at some point put g4 and f5 and
start an attack against the black king
we have Queen to b6 making room for the
a pawn and now comes look the B 1
preparing ideas like a four we have H a
a six and now h3 saying either you
capture a capture of my knight or move
back with the Bishop Bishop to f5 and
now of course you could capture here and
after Knight capture start g4 maybe
first King H 2 and then g4 but
Capablanca goes goes about it
differently first he pushes g4
immediately now black has to decide what
to do with the Bishop Bishop captures on
c2 display we have Queen captures and
now it's one of those moments when
you're playing with the black pieces and
you have to decide is is allowing white
to push f5 better or worse than you
yourself pushing f5 because if you are
self pushing a 5 then you've already
given white a past epon and here yeah I
mean if you try something like any any
move then f5 will be very strong already
f6 is a threat and well after F 6 e 6 is
coming it's just not not better than
immediately going for f5 so here
blackburn immediately pushes f5 and we
have king to h2 by capablanca
of course you don't want to do something
like capture then you
black a very nice outpost for his night
on f5 so King to h2 improving the
position of the King also freeing the G
file for your rooks we have nice to see
six now tree maneuvering the night over
to e6 we have looked at g1 backup of
Lanka and here blackburn doesn't go
about it correctly he makes a mistake
Queen to d8 was was a very important
move here but it's well it's it becomes
clear when it's needed but you'll see
why here black bongos night to b8 and
this will be a problem cover Blanca goes
G captures on f5 will we have rook
captures on f5 and now comes nice to 84
and this night to h4 is the problem if
Queen to d8 was played a night stage 4
would not have been possible and black
just continues playing normally here
white pushes the rug back and black
simply doesn't have enough time we look
to h5 now attacking the knight but it's
far too late
Capablanca plays Knight factor son g6 we
have H capture some g6 and now rook
captures on g6 would an attack on the
Queen and it's just a you know it's not
even a sacrifice white now has two
connected passports which are about to
start marching forward the knight is a
very awkwardly placed there on the 8th
the rook is undeveloped so it's
basically like black is down material
and here if you play something like
Queen to c7 trying to you know help out
with the defense here just Ruby g1 is
coming it's it is just a nice attack if
you go night here then f5 is coming if
you defend with the rook still f5 is
coming and f6 and white why do just wins
this so blackburn tried a different
defense after rook to g6 he tried Queen
to b8 making an idea of rook to a7 to
help out with the defense of the g7
square but here it's it also doesn't
work couple Blanca makes now mix and
makes it work even faster so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning attack for white here I will
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
the Black Death on a Sunday and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
rook captures on g7 no fooling around
King captures and rook to g1 and now it
doesn't really matter where the King
goes the queen is coming all the way to
g6 we have King to f8 and now Queen
comes to g6 with an attack on the rocker
here and there's no way to actually save
the rook for example if you go something
like group to h8 e sex is coming and
after sounding like Queen a7 you get
Queen to f6 check you're gonna pick up
the rook your own rupees controlling the
G file King gate Queen captures and now
it's you know just everything loses Ruby
g7 check after 9 blocks your own Queen
is under attack but it doesn't really
matter
rook captures King here Queenie 5 chair
King has to moon I would capture the
Queen and it's it's just all over so
here black Baron decided to give up the
rook rook captures on h3 we have King
captures on h3 and it was in this
position that Joseph Henry Blackburn
whom they also called the Black Death
resigned in the game why did he resign
well his pieces are just terrible and
white actually has a forced checkmate so
there's that but after something like
Quincy 8 check King has to move or you
can put a 5 you can just block it
Knight f7 or or you can bring the rook
into the game doesn't really matter but
whatever you play the the e6 is coming
it's I mean just terrible King e8 now
you can even win the Queen here or you
can just deliver checkmate King bee 7
Queen captures King goes here g6 Queen
has the block and now rook captures will
be checkmate nobody on a black board did
not wait for that after King to h3
he resigned the game but him before I
forget this as this was the last game of
the first part of the 1914 tournament in
some feature Berg let's check out the
standings yes we do have them now these
are the standings the preliminary
cross-table Capablanca first with 8
points that's insane that's one and a
half point ahead of world champion
Emanuel Lasker and Ziggler tarush so
parish and Lasker tied for second with
six and a half
then it's election with six and Marshall
with six so these are the five
contestants that are going they are
going into the second part of the
tournament and they are going into a
double round-robin then we have
Bernstein with five Rubinstein would
five Rubinstein had had a great
tournament and he played the great chess
but he lost one game to 11 and one game
to Lasker and that was enough to kick
him out of the out of the top five which
you know as capablanca said before the
tournament even started that he held
even the Rubenstein or Alaska to win the
tournament as favorites but yeah two
losses against the objection and the
last hair and there you have it already
or already seventh under list names of
each with four joseph henry blackburn
would three-and-a-half yanovskiy with
three-and-a-half and Isidor ginsburg
with one point only two draws in last
place swim that's it for the first part
of the tournament like I said do check
out the other games by Joseph a neural
diagram where we talk a bit more about
about this gentleman it will be the
first two links in the description
you'll also feel free to check it out
the videos are a bit older but you know
you can also enjoy that as well so I
would like to thank DB Robert Harrison
good Anwar where there's really a
Matthew Harris and Andrew Knight for a
contribution to my channel think a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous videos your thing
called for watching and I will see you
soon are continuing the second part of
the 1914 tournaments in some feature
Berg and you know as usual checking up
on stuff thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday